et le césar du meilleur film est
attribué à
les musées rarogne à cannes le nom
d'oscar acclamé par la critique prisé
par le public avec plus de 2 millions
d'entrées laventure les misérables
s'achève ce soir par la consécration 16
heures avec quatre trophées dont ceux du
meilleur film
c'est le film le plus primé ce soir
c'est la septième fois
quand les acteurs s'imposant cette
catégorie avec son premier film
d'après bruno nuytten cyril collard
disons qu'à guillaume gallienne et
xavier legrand l'an passé pour jusqu'à
la garde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon bah je suis très émus très émus très
content très fier
j'ai quand même préparé un petit
discours que je vais vous lire alors je
tiens à remercier les membres de
l'académie et les deux millions de
personnes qui sont allées voir les
misérables en salle je suis fier d'avoir
mis la lumière sur ma ville clichy
montfermeil
les hymnes et misérable ce ne sont pas
que les habitants des cités la misère
touche hélas de plus en plus de
françaises et de français
on m'a souvent demandé quel était le la
morale de ce film elle est simple nous
vivons draper blessé et c'est la
pauvreté qui divisent les français
il est temps de baisser les armes il est
temps de s'unir il est temps de montrer
qu'on fait tous partie du même pays la
france est notre pays faisant un grand
pays
le seul ennemi ce n'est pas l'autre
c'est la misère merci à vous
bonsoir
on est on est extrêmement heureux c'est
un c'est un film qui vient de loin
pourtant il a été tourné à 15 km de
paris on est tellement heureux de cette
récompense et et on voulait dire aussi
que le cinéma français avec une belle
année notre histoire est celle des films
nommés avec nous n'est pas dénué de sens
et s'inscrivent dans notre patrie belle
époque
florence foresti et sandrine kiberlain
ont parlé de tous les films qui sont
emparés de deux sujets sociaux
extrêmement fort on peut y voir quelque
chose d'inquiétant nous on a envie d'y
voir si quelque chose de rassurant
si ces teams ont pu fédérer c'est que
chacun peut y retrouver sa part
d'humanité et qui pourtant quelque chose
d'universel
on tient évidemment à remercier tous
ceux qui ont partagé ses convictions
avec nous autour de autour de ce film
merci ladj pour ta confiance en ton
boulot pour ta force
merci à tous les techniciens les
comédiens et les habitants de
montfermeil qui nous ont aidés à bouger
les montagnes merci à leur incident et
bérangère de termonde canal+ vous avez
été les premiers à croire à nos
histoires de lyon volley de gitans au
bord de la crise de nerfs et de mère qui
n'en est pas vraiment un
vincent girerd ce n'est plus la région
ile de france
notre co producteur edouard weil merci
pour tout et edward et puis rock ce
terreau landes et sarah nos cousins
américains
merci les gars
continuent dans la lancée pour l'émotion
grand merci à sylvie pialat qui nous a
beaucoup donné
petite dédicace et en même temps du fond
du coeur à humbert balsan
voilà pour plein de grandes raisons va
dire merci à jean labadie vincent
maraval toute cette équipe
le pacte wild bunch vous avez été
incroyable vous nous avez poussé et fait
confiance merci vraiment les gars ça
fait plaisir
un merci à thierry frémaux pierre
lescure et le comité de sélection qui
nous ont offert à cannes un mégaphone
absolue pour porter la voix des
misérables on a réussi à faire ce film
ensemble
grâce à cette énergie contagieuse est
animé par un sentiment d'urgence
peu importe le manque de moyens nous
savions que nous ferions coûte que coûte
s'il pouvait donner à nos gouvernants la
même énergie afin qu'il peut afin qu'ils
puissent changer les choses aussi ce
serait sympa et espérer que produire des
films collen comme les misérables sera
bientôt devenu anachronique beaucoup de
débats et de combat pour la transparence
la parité la diversité l'égalité
l'heureux le renouvellement des
générations à nîmes le cinéma français
en ce moment c'est bien sain et
nécessaire mais si nous devons
transformer l'essai il faut que nous
fassions de manière unie collectif car
ces combats sont les mêmes et
reconnaissons le on est une chance
incroyable de pouvoir faire notre métier
merci vous
je veux juste dire en remerciant bien
évidemment non collective ce collectif
kourtrajmé qui avec qui on fait des
films pendant plus de 20 ans kim
chapiron en magasin ou monnet seger ljr
ici présents mouloud achour
vincent cassel mathieu kassovitz qui
étaient là sur scène voilà merci à vous
une aventure incroyable et ça fait que
commencer on va continuer à faire des
films à ouvrir les portes et je vais
aussi remercié à les élèves de notre
école l'école kourtrajmé qui existe
depuis plus de deux ans et une énergie
incroyable donc un grand grand merci à
tous les élèves on croit énormément vous
on espère que vous arriverez aussi à
faire des beaux films voilà merci arts
de rue merci à bientôt